today
ukrainians are not only defending their
country from the evil of Putin and his
enablers they are defending their rights
the principles of the U.N Charter and
the values of freedom and democracy that
so many of us hold dear
there's no option but victory for
Ukraine
Canada will be there to support
Ukraine's fight for freedom for as long
as it takes
and once they win
we will help them to recover
last week I was in Ukraine to reform
just that
I met with courageous and resilient
ukrainians from all walks of life
who are passionate about rebuilding
Ukraine once they are victorious
in our conversation it was clear
for reconstruction to be inclusive and
enduring it must address both the
physical and invisible impacts of
Putin's war on men women and children
victims of the war
and so we must tackle the psychological
marks of the war with the same
seriousness and urgency as the physical
scars
to heal the trauma that has been
inflicted on the population we must
support survivors in Seeking Justice
this pursuit of accountability will be
essential to achieving lasting peace in
Ukraine
the efforts ukrainians are making to
provide relief to their fellow citizens
even as the war rages is inspiring in a
world Awash in too much suffering
it drove home for me the need for the
International Community of all of us to
continue helping Ukraine
let me be clearer Russia's war on
Ukraine is unjustified it is illegal
Russian forces have committed and
continued to commit indiscriminate and
impelling acts across Ukraine they have
destroyed entire cities targeted
hospitals and playgrounds in an act of
incredible horror they have ripped
children away from their homes
they have taken the lives of too many
families
in Ukraine I met with a prosecutor
General to discuss his work to gather
evidence and prosecute those responsible
for crimes linked to the war including
conflict-related sexual violence
healing as we speak with some 60 000
cases
and this number climbs with each passing
day
the details included in each are
horrific yet those figures do not
provide a full picture of the widespread
human suffering occurring each of the
363 days of Putin's War
for every individual who is willing to
tell their story many others go
unreported due to the stigma and
feelings of Shame as mentioned by first
lady Alaska
zelinska a bit earlier and I also met
with Ukrainian police officers
psychologists prosecutors and
investigators who are working to
investigate and prosecute these crimes
while supporting survivors of this
violence and Canada will continue to
support them
those responsible for this suffering
will answer for their crimes they will
be met with the full force of the law
Tana welcomes Ukraine's case against
Russia at the international court of
justice and we continue to support the
international Criminal Court's efforts
in Ukraine
we have also joined the core group
launched by Ukraine my friend mitro in
examining the proposal to establish a
special tribunal on the crime of
aggression a crime which may not fall
within the scope of existing
institutions
together we will leave no stone unturned
as we identify the most effective ways
to hold Russia accountable for its crime
of aggression
this is also aimed at deterring others
who are watching us considering if they
could ever challenge the rules
the emergency session of the general
assembly will meet today and vote
tomorrow on a resolution on U.N Charter
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine and
Canada calls on all member states to
support the resolution and through it to
continue supporting the principles of
the U.N Charter and the people of
Ukraine thank you yes